welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 finale puts it up
with some of the best storytelling in
the MCU but could it have been better I
don't know about that but headwriter
Eric Martin revealed that the ending of
the show was almost very different
before Marvel nked it what was the
mystery nuked Branch timeline of Loki
season 2 we're going to talk about it
today because this is a sneak peek where
we take the temperature of whatever
we're watching while we head into the
next episode or look ahead to the next
week in nerd Dum but this week we're
looking back a bit joining me on this
episode of the sneak peek my god of
stories it's mod Garrett I think it's no
coincidence that God and mod rhyme to
Americans yes but but not in other
countries it's just here in America
that's it I become a God over here I
love it and by the way if you want to
hear us talk about the ending of season
2 in Loki's fate head on over to the
breakroom channel for our inside Marvel
after show okay mod let's get into this
ahead of the finale on Thursday night
head riter Eric Martin spoke with script
magazine and I don't think anyone else
really saw this I just saw Eric Martin
tweet this I was like no why is no one
talking about this in that interview he
talked about his experience writing on
the show and he revealed that the
original concept for episode 5 was
totally different before Marvel exec
nked it in his words now just to give um
some context on this um Marvel is
getting supposedly better about putting
like head writers and showrunners those
being writers in charge of their shows
but loky season 2 was still kind of in
the old way of doing things where they
would like have uh an executive in this
case it was Kevin Wright who's kind of
like the creative final say on
everything but then uh with Loki though
with the great work that Michael Waldren
did in season 1 and Eric Martin was
there in season one to they they gave
him I think more control over it but at
the end of the day the Marvel Brain
Trust weighs in on everything and that
Brain Trust includes Kevin feige Lou
espito Mary leanos um a lot of the names
that you see Brad wbom and Kevin Wright
is on that Brain Trust as well Nate
Moore um and they can like veto or over
overrule anything um but there was this
episode 5 concept that everyone in the
writer staff and many of these
Executives were like this is our
favorite episode of of the show um and
uh you know I I got to say I'm not at
all disappointed with any of what we got
U mod you might disagree there but
interestingly this episode episode 5 was
apparently the episode that hooked the
series directors Benson and Morehead and
then they had to Nuke that episode so
Eric Martin said quote it would have
been one of the stranger things that the
MCU had had ever done it was a big swing
it was a really big conceptual swing and
I think dramatic swing when that got
nuked it was funny because that was the
thing where people would stop me in the
hallways like oh man I'm so sorry that
was my favorite episode Martin also said
that I got nuked so late in the process
that he had to write a new episode 5
script over the course of a weekend so
mod what do you think happened here well
I I do think that um because Martin also
goes to say that his Focus was putting
emotions first so the the emotions are
supposed to carry the story and I think
that even though he wrote that episode
in a weekend you can tell that the
emotion was there like I thought it was
a very good job sort of feeling loss
feeling Loki's Journey uh getting to the
bottom of lok's deep desire uh really
understanding Sylvie as well um bringing
that team together in a way that I think
Marvel does so well but the fact that
other writers and other creatives in the
Marvel space were saying
that's the best episode and I think it
sounds like if they had gone with that
it would have been a huge risk but it
would have paid off and I'm so almost
like Curious trying not to be devastated
of what that episode could have been and
why it was nuked is it because it would
have affected the outcome of season um
of the Season 2 or is it because it was
just pushing sort of like the envelope
too far but I feel out of any show that
could really push its limits it's Loki
this is where you can kind of go batshit
um and make that exciting television was
episode 5 good it was could I tell that
it was a filler episode yes I truly do
think it was filler I I think that it
was contained enough where the start of
the episode and the end of the episode
were probably the same and it was all
the in in the middle um the meat that I
don't think had enough progress of the
plot or the story and I know people have
disagreed with me in the comments when
they made that argument after our
episode 5 breakdown obviously don't cry
over spilled milk or you know don't
mourn don't count your chickens before
they hatch or any of those sort of
sayings but you're right we're not
talking about this and I'm the kind of
queen of chaos to wonder what does it
take to get a show idea nuked I want to
know I know yeah cuz my thinking is they
went pretty far the the creat creative
and structural depths that they mind are
as far as really my imagination could go
when I was thinking of how the finale
could because the finale episode went
pretty far I mean Loki Groundhog Day
back through the events of the series
all the way back to season 1 that's
really as far as I thought it could go
so you got to think how much further
could it have gone and just so we're
clear you're not alone mod and sensing
that like this shorter episode 5 really
felt like a a a quick reconception of
some other idea I believe our colleagues
over on the midnight boys had a similar
reaction and I think if you the viewer
had that reaction too like oh I I
thought it was going to go crazier than
that I think that's completely valid um
but a lot of times on TV shows and I
only just say this as uh a guy who has
friends writing on TV shows um including
some of the Marvel shows uh or is
pitching on these Marvel shows often the
it's not like writers get bored with the
own their own format of the show but
what is often considered internally the
most celebrated thing is something that
most breaks the mold So like um my
friend Allison wrote on BoJack Horseman
and wrote the amazing view from halfway
down episode which breaks the formula
and is almost like its own bottle
episode but is one of the greatest
episodes of that series but it also is
not like in many ways a typical episode
of Bojack Horsemen but she's such a
brilliant writer that it very much fit
in with the themes and the journey of
Bojack but that often is what gets uh
the gets celebrated something that
breaks the convention um so it doesn't
necessarily mean it's like the greatest
episode in this case of of Loki all both
both of the two seasons uh but I think
it is something that it most breaks the
episode so if we're doing some forensic
analysis of what the episode 5 that we
got was what did it do it picks up with
Loki after the events of the Loom
explosion um it introduces the origin
stories of each of the variants
B15 um Mobius Casey and OB um and it
doesn't go uh much further into b15s
origin in fact she is ver Willis but it
didn't go much into that this show um
Ren Slayer and Hunter uh X5 pretty much
disappeared from the show and Miss G for
the final two miss m g I feel like Miss
M's character had substantial buildup in
the earlier episodes that we didn't
really see payoff and and the fact that
um ver Willis was a doctor during New
York in 20 or in New York in 2012 so
here's my prediction of or my theory of
what got nuked I think uh Martin Benson
and and Morehead wanted to go back
throughout MCU history and pull another
endgame um go back to the Battle of New
York go back to the events of 2011 Thor
go back to Thor of the Dark World go
back to Ragnarok and then go back to
other events that may be tied in with
that the fact that the Battle of New
York was like a NEX point that tight in
not only Loki's escape with the Tess Rak
that kicked off the Loki series but like
Hawkeye we know had connections to that
I would have I wonder if like we could
have gone back to the events of endgame
and then seen like The Avengers in their
time suits in an alley and Hulk is just
kind of like smashing a cab
half-heartedly and we could have done up
Back to the Future and looped again back
on those events I mean I can understand
why that would have gotten nuked and
it's not because it wasn't a brilliant
idea it's because of money it's because
of like the ST power need for all that
kind of stuff it's because they yeah it
was just way it was dreaming very big um
yeah this the star power required and
even if you didn't require actors to
come back cuz I imagine they might have
had a couple different angles that they
could have like repurposed or just had
Loki appear in the background of that
same shot and composited him time
slipping through it um what I think what
it was is maybe creatively because cuz
Eric Martin admits he's like it might
have been too big and it was the right
decision to Nuke it I wonder if like
like no Marvel exx are like we've
already gone back to that well too many
times we've already gone back to the
Battle of New York and I think maybe cuz
the fact that Verity Willis is in 2012
New York to me that just sounds like it
is the ghost it is the corpse of some
other idea that like in the last few
hours of the night Eric Martin had to be
like ah I don't have time to come with
like a new story for B15 but I really
like that she is this character so I'm
going to keep a shell of that in this
script as a little clue with very little
depth yeah it's just and you're right
there's such a coincidence that that is
the time and place um for it to not kind
of explore uh also we didn't really get
mentions of the blip uh and what
happened in that time either um but that
I I guess it's because that's not the
focus the focus is that this is all
bigger than that you know um we are
dealing with time and timelines and
variants um I wonder though my little
theory is that mayhaps uh the finale was
going to be different I wonder if they
had written two different outcomes
whether there would be a season 3 or if
there wouldn't be a season 3 so I wonder
if SE if Episode 5 was going to set off
sort of what a very different conclusion
could have been um and I wonder if we
got this specific ending instead of a
Kang Dynasty instead of something else
completely because there was some setup
initially it did take a little bit of a
swift turn a change at the end and I
think that there was season 3 like you
know where end of season one we got that
massive Cliffhanger um maybe we we're
leading up to a cliffhanger for an
additional season and then one was no
we're not going to renew but we need to
cover all bases depending on which way
it's going to go you know Eric Martin
did say and this is just what he said in
interviews um it's where they arrived at
is that they viewed season one and two
as two halves of a book like first half
of the book is uh season 1 second half
of the book closes the book on the TVA
and that's what season 2 is but we don't
know when that decision was made
and I think the the scene we have to
look at is Ren Slayer I just think the
way Ren Slayer is left on this show if
that is the last we see of her that is
the really in my opinion the only flaw
of this finale because it's just such
like an undeveloped storyline of she
just gets pruned from episode 4 that's
why I think she would have had more in
episode 5 and that original draft agree
and you mentioned the blip mod MH where
was uh uh Rebecca torin's origin as a
high school principal in 2018 I think
this they specifically and Eric Martin
wrote on season 1 as well I think they
strategically put these characters as
specific years in history where they
could have gone back to The Well of MCU
Infinity Saga history you want to look
at NEX events as well you want to look
at things that absolutely you know
caused I think they wanted to revisit
the blip they wanted to revisit the
Battle of New York but I think I mean
the Loki writers were writing the first
season of Loki I think with the season 2
in mind and then what ended up happening
is all these shows started to kind of
reference the B Hawkeye referenced the
blip where they showed yena Bova going
through it w Vision showed it with
Monica Rambo going through it so maybe
that's why the Marvel Executives were
like you know what no we've just we've
just done it too many times it's going
to make yeah you guys are going to look
like you're derivative of these other
things even though it was part of your
original design at this point you got to
come up with something different uh and
I think what we got of like Alcatraz was
like freaking cool like I I loved that
we visited Alcatraz and and it was like
DB Cooper kind of idea you know Casey
completely changed as a character when
you learned his backstory which I found
was interesting um but it was a all bit
shoehorned for me it wasn't you know I I
I I now that I've leared that it was
quite rushed and written in sort of a
weekend I I kind of get that I just
think shout out
to Mr Eric Martin for making his
colleagues like Jaw drop so well done
whatever that was even though we'll
never see the lot of day good on your
butt will yeah and that's why I think it
would have been a crazy budget thing but
I don't I think episode 6 was mostly
locked in because like the way it's it
Loops back to the Citadel the way it
Loops back to that uh interrogation room
time theater 25 and I think Loki become
like creating his own Loom that
beautiful sequence I think that would
have required so much previs so much
design I think there's no way that that
was like reconfigured I think that was
always the destined end of season 2 and
really episode 5 was just kind of like
whatever it was was extracted and then
what we got was was snuck in and I think
yeah that's what it was I have just one
last thing I didn't get to say when we
did our recap I know that I was a bit a
bit sad that I was mourning sort of like
the Destiny or the glory uh glorious
purpose of Loki what would have been
sick and I'd love to run it by you cuz
you might be like no more that'll wreck
everything but what if right at the end
when he's sitting on on that new Throne
holding all of the branches um you know
with that gorgeous symbolism and it kind
of closes in on him and he Winks oh oh
no like that's what he wanted all along
so that was like always the goal even
though he does say I don't even want the
throne but what if he's
like not that I would have hated it I
just would have hated the way the
internet reacted to it because you would
have had some people who hated it and
started trashing the show and you would
have had some people who just like blew
it way out of proportion um for like
what it really means I just want him to
be happy I do too I think he is I think
Tom hson gave us just enough of a little
smile and that's that's it that's that's
him listening to some of Taylor Swift's
songs and realizing she's happy and he
can be happy too is Zoe Ashton yeah that
crushing Marvel at the moment so go
power couple all right I just thought I
throw it out there I wanted to test it
let us know in the comments below what
you think this Mystery episode was and I
again think as a a Marvel exec not
necessarily big or violent or offensive
but rather just something that like
creatively something Eric Martin might
agree with might be the way uh to go
when you change it uh anyway be sure to
check out nerd rot. shop you can always
grab the latest and greatest of new
rockstars gear we just put up a new
shirt design inspired by the finale God
of stories you can grab that shirt
before the holiday season officially
kicks into gear support this Channel and
check out our great merch options over
at nerd riot. shop and don't forget to
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network new rockstars the
break room and the Deep dive and hey you
can come hang out with us in person at
our upcoming Los Angeles live show this
Thursday November 16th tickets are on
sale now in the link in the description
and mod I'm going to have to apologize
to all the attendees over getting um
that Jack McDonald's Theory wrong the
soilent green pie Theory wrong I got
quite a few things wrong I still think
think they're eating the bodies of
variance in the pie like come on let do
you think the automat still open in the
happy ending version of the TVA at the
end maybe maybe I hope not this video
was sponsored by Helix sleep who has
cyberweek deals available now with up to
25% off your purchase for a limited time
and look I get it finding the perfect
mattress can be difficult but helix's
sleep quiz makes it so easy you just
take the quiz and Helix finds the
perfect mattress for you I wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool and I got matched with
the dusk luux Helix mattress Helix
delivers your mattress right to your
door with free shipping in the US the
mattress comes rolled up in a box and
it's super easy to set up yourself Helix
has a 100 night sleep trial so you get
more than 3 months to make make sure
that you love your mattress Helix
mattresses have a 10-year warranty Helix
even offers financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away I love
my Helix mattress I think you would too
if you're looking for a new bed check
out Helix sleep they have great
cyberweek deals available now it's the
perfect time to update your sleep with
25% off a helix mattress plus two free
pillows click the link below or go to
helixsleep.com rockstars to find out
more about this limited time offer I
have a a couple of things I want to chat
about news wise because there has been a
lot of news happening at the moment we
on this show do usually look ahead um
but this is kind of going to be a really
interesting next year with Marvel
because we've only now got one Marvel
movie on slate for next year that is
Deadpool 3 um C apparently Captain Brave
New World is going through some
extensive
re-shoot so that's going to be pushed
back Fantastic 4 is 202 5 uh
Thunderbolts is 2025 blade it's going to
be my mom's birthday 2025 Kang Dynasty
2026 Secret Wars
2027 we are getting one Marvel movie
next year how do you feel about that
great take all the time you need to make
these movies good I think that is the
biggest lesson we've learned from the um
from the most recent era ever since
endgame is Marvel has just tried to do
too much and they have spread themselves
thin um our colleague Joanna Robinson
who was a co-writer of the amazing MCU
the re of Marvel Studios book um while
promoting this book she's um she gave an
interview I can't remember where I heard
it but someone was just asking her like
what like what does Marvel what does
Kevin feige need to do to get Marvel
back on track and Joanna just said two
words do less yeah do less yeah because
Kevin feige is uh truly a great
Visionary for how these adaptations will
work but uh and and you know what his
executives are pretty good too but he
could not oversee everything that they
were doing they were trying to make too
many shows at the same time and if you
go look at the history of Marvel Studios
back in the early days and Phase 2 they
did have a a writers program where they
were producing a ton of scripts but none
of them saw the light of day until they
got so that's how we got like the runway
runaways that's how we got Luke Cage
that all came out of that program um and
Nicole Pearlman the great writer came
out of that program so they end some of
them ended up getting assigned to
scripts but like they really did treat
it as experimentation whereas what they
did with the Disney Plus shows is
basically all the people they would have
had that program that program is no
longer there anymore but they
essentially just like green lit a ton of
stuff and we saw a lot of it and I don't
think I mean I don't get me wrong I I'm
not going to be like oh we got too much
Marvel content but like I think it
really really confused a lot of viewers
it diluted the brand and um so just
having one big Deadpool movie I'm I'm
fine with that I'm fine with we have
yeah we had won Avengers movie in 2012
do you know what that says to me I mean
The Avengers movie in 2012 like it it
thrusts sort of like the storytelling
into sort of a next tier I find because
you did all the origins and then you
brought the team together I think that
that says to me that Deadpool 3 they are
backing this movie they are very proud
of this movie they think it's going to
absolutely crush and that one movie is
enough to sustain the year so I am now
so excited for Deadpool even though
we've got to wait sort of seven eight
months um that to me I think says a lot
uh now we'll have one one movie we might
have some like Disney plus stuff as well
like I believe um Agatha darkhole
Diaries is scheduled for later in
2024 I'm very excited for that um but
like one Marvel movie I think it's fine
I mean if you look at the Marvel movies
that came out in
2023 um like Quantum Mania was clearly
rushed I think the Marvels was pretty
rushed um I think Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 was the only one that
like really was the true vision of of
what that director intended it to be so
I guess my only concern with pushing
those dates back especially for Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars is that I would
have thought that season 2 finale of
Loki was kind of going to lead into that
but with that delay it's sort of lost
all flow of that coherent storyline what
do you think's going to happen with Kang
and Secret Wars now that it's way away
yeah I can't even that seems so distant
to me 2027 like you know my my kids's
going to be like four like I I can't I
don't know what my life is going to be
like at that point the way I looked at
the finale of Loki at least the way they
got this Final Cut I really did think
they just tried to end it yeah on its
own the closest we got to setting up the
the Kang Dynasty were like two things
one Kang's uh he remains saying like hey
there's going to be infinite numbers of
me out there and Loki saying I I'll get
them all yeah um and then two that case
File report that said not only there was
Ruckus In The quantum realm there were
other related case File incidents on
that paperwork and right now I'm
desperately trying to like zoom and
inhance and address the contrast on that
to see what these other related
incidents are because I think all those
related incidents are the other kangs in
the arena I think they just really
buried these in the episode because they
don't want to be too beholden on like
the future of the Kang Dynasty and look
I I got some heat recently when I did
the uh an invincible breakdown where I
said if Marvel wants to move away from
Kang that wouldn't be the end of the
world um and it's only just because Kang
as a character doesn't have as much
richness as uh Dr Doom or or like Thanos
did um Kang was like a bunch of
different characters that Marvel Comics
just kind of shoved together into one
character and the coolest thing about
them is that they were just whacka but
any one Kang on their own I think the
most interesting Kang ever was was like
one the fact that we had Nate Richards
the Young The Young Avenger iron lad and
that kid feeling like his fate is
destined to be a a super villain and
then two the um Mark Wade Avengers
Unleashed Kang War storyline from 2017
where we learned about Kang Prime and
then I just really like how Vision
treats it like a a Hitler baby
proposition
um but other than that like I've never
you know there's not a whole lot of mine
out of the character and and the way
they've done it in the MCU has been
pretty fun but really just in Loki I
think we saw in an man the was Quan
Mania like that is really what you have
with Kang when you when you make them
like a a juliia Caesar type figure it's
they're not as but now now Loki
superseded that L's far more powerful
than Kang he's like you know in that
position I think he Rivals Kang I think
are now like Loki is saying here's my
vision of it what do you think I think
he's still vulnerable Loki did the
equivalent of going into the hyperbolic
Time Chamber when he did centuries of
math and figuring out every single play
this guy in a in a single moment has
become brilliant so I think that Loki is
so powerful that it's almost disrupted
this whole Kang Dynasty at all I don't
know that's that's a thing it's like I
would have thought that the end of
season 2 would have been the Catalyst
into Kang Dynasty and it hasn't been and
it's almost self-contained now I don't
think there's going to be a season 3 um
you still think there's that that there
could be a season three and you think
that maybe um Eric Martin's going to be
back on for that one perhaps I don't
know if Eric Martin will come back I
just thinking I think there is room for
a season 3 if Marvel wants to do it uh
but I right now mod I'm with you I don't
think there will be one um just because
that Marvel right now really does seem
to be pulling in and circling the wagons
like I don't think they want to just
Greenlight something that they have to
like commit to and deliver on um but
yeah I I I don't see this as a setup
right away for Kang Dynasty it just
seems too distant um I I see it more as
a setup for maybe another Multiverse
story maybe Deadpool 3 or something like
that we might make it a reference to it
but I think that I I don't want to spoil
anything but it seems like with this um
Multiverse and branches we're we're
going to sort of steer away from the
gods and superheroes that we've seen and
it's going to take a different sort of
mutated step maybe yeah um I I I think
right now like doing a true Multiverse
uh Saga you have to have the right
people in play to it it's worked with
Loki we had some fun with it with with
the spider men in um in no way home but
really you need to introduce the
Fantastic 4 before you can have like a
real Multiverse Saga like it's it's
tough we have to it it almost really
just works when you have a character
who's already appeared on the ground so
much that now you're ready to to take
them out and throughout the Multiverse
so that's going to happen May 2nd 2025
that's oh that's when fantastic port's
coming yeah so that's saying like the
the 2024 Marvel movies in my opinion
don't need to have anything to do with
the Multiverse oh I'm sorry I meant the
2025 movies yeah other than like
Fantastic 4 I think the other ones
Thunderbolts um cap 4 and blade don't
need to go into the Multiverse okay mod
let's do our heat check with a huge week
for Marvel and a lot of news about 2024
production delays let's just kind of
take the temperature of the MCU right
now are we think do you think we're
still on an upswing or is there still
more Valley to get through what do you
think I think that Loki has delivered in
terms of quality uh instead of quantity
uh they are not churning out sort of 10
episodes I think that they've done the
best with those episodes in terms of
Storytelling um I think you're exactly
right they are going to slow their role
when you look at sort of the last few
years and the things that they've
introduced that haven't gone anywhere
Harry Styles was in eternals what's
going on with eternals what's going on
with that character there's been quite a
few carrot dangles and now it's like
there's a field of freaking carrots and
someone feels like corn you know like I
don't know I just feel like there were
way too many cooks or there were way too
many ideas they were the branching this
is why you need a sacred timeline I'm
kidding I'm kidding but I me Kevin feige
was asked by Ash about this on the red
carpet's like Kevin uh uh um Harry
Styles is interested and excited we're
excited and it's like what does that
mean what do you mean yeah we're all
excited SS like you promised something
and there may be some contracts at play
here but there was just too many ideas
and it needed to be streamlined here's
what I'm excited for um I I think Marvel
is not dead and I'm just I I what what
really bugs me it just makes me laugh
about this narrative that like Marvel's
dead and right now you know it's Sunday
when this is coming out so I'm sure
there's going to be a lot of Buzz around
the Marvel's box office performance and
a lot of people are going to be like see
told you so I understand that people on
the internet may say that I think folks
who work in the media and talk about
movies for a living you should know
better you know like just look at every
other movie studio they would kill to
trade places with Marvel Studios right
now regardless of the mo of the Marvel's
box office performance maybe maybe not
Universal because Universal's had a hell
of a year with Mario and Oppenheimer um
so maybe they aren't feeling that way
Zelda
movie with AIA Rod woohoo so excited for
that
go I think like with Loki it is I I can
understand if you think like numbers may
be off but these the creative Triumph of
of Loki and how much fun the Marvels was
and how much fun Iman volani is like I
think no other like movie studio has
something that is still that strong of a
franchise to where people are still
going to come back for Deadpool 3 and
Fantastic 4 you know like uh that's why
I say Marvel's best days are still ahead
of it because I think people overpraise
the infinity Saga which was still an
amazing accomplishment but they did it
without like the coolest characters in
Marvel Canon like we have a future with
a Fantastic Four coming back and with
X-Men showing up like how can you say
that Marvel's best days are behind it
where for many years all we had to work
with was like Ant-Man and Thor I think
we've all said you know enough about how
off some of the Thor movies are can they
look they all do good work I think Chris
Hemsworth has been great for the MCU he
been great Australia he's been great for
a lot of things but like it's just like
I think people view the infinity Saga as
this flawless un unimpeachable thing and
that there's no way Marvel Studios can
top it and it's like cool your jets like
the infinity Saga was an incredible
Triumph but I think it was because
everything was going in that direction
and then it paid off you know so that
was like structurally what they were
doing with all their programming with
all the movies with with the characters
it came together it was great um and
then you have something like Loki where
I just I mean I think it's so clever
that they open up the drawer and there
are Infinity Stones in there you know so
you just get a real scale sense of what
nearly you know what the whole precipice
of endgame and all of that was all about
with these Infinity Stones and then they
are so obsolete you know they have no
power and they mean nothing in the TVA
so I thought that that was a really
really cool shift uh what I think's
happening I think the strike has forced
these networks to take a beat instead of
that churning instead of hitting those
deadlines instead of making sure that
there's you know a lot of wheels turning
there was a forced pause and in that I
think they're kind of reassessing DC's
been doing it for a little while and I
think that this pause has meant that
they are right we we've done that one
we're going into a new a whole new
vision whole new phase um you know
buckle up the rides just beginning and I
think Marvel also said okay we did the
next thing and now it's like take a beat
what's this upcoming slate look like
what do we need what's important um yeah
I just think that this time off yes it's
going to push things back but I do think
that there is going to be more of a
focus on quality over quantity and that
is the difference between sort of like
Loki and a secret Invasion kind of thing
absolutely well we'll leave it there for
this episode of the sneak peek ma it's
been great chatting with you and and
thanks for joining us every week on uh
inside Marvel just being a ble to talk
about Loki with you throughout these
past couple months has just been amazing
it's been great and thank you for having
me and thank you for letting me have
some quite outlandish theories from time
to time we wouldn't have it any other
way mod so follow mod on Twitter atod
Garrett you can uh follow me at eaos
I'll see you all next week uh and thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
everybody